[Musik]
raketenalarm in jerusalem bei
auseinandersetzungen zwischen israelis
und palästinensern werden mehr als 300
menschen verletzt
von ostfriesland bis oberammergau in
immer mehr landkreisen sinkt die
inzidenz immer mehr corona
beschränkungen werden aufgehoben
spitzenkandidatur für die bundestagswahl
parteichefin wissler und fraktionschef
bartsch sollen die linke in den
wahlkampf führen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster heute abend und herzlich
willkommen bei den heute -nachrichten
mit mir in dieser woche für sie da ist
norbert lehmann für den sport ein
sogenannter von mir und wir beginnen dem
nahen osten wo jerusalem derzeit die
schwersten auseinandersetzungen seit
jahren erlebt in der umgebung schlugen
am nachmittag mehrere raketen aus dem
gazastreifen abgefeuert von der
islamistischen hamas die fordert
ultimativ dass alle israelischen
sicherheitskräfte vom tempelberg
abziehen
zuvor wurden bei zusammenstößen mehr als
300 palästinenser und rund 20 polizisten
verletzt
israel feiert heute den sogenannten
jerusalem tag er erinnert daran dass
israelische soldaten 1967 den osten der
stadt eroberten also den teil jerusalems
den die palästinenser als hauptstadt für
ihren angestrebten staates beanspruchen
michael beverunger berichtet es ist die
befürchtete eskalation der gewalt ein
raketen handel geht von gaza aus über
dem südlichen israel nieder
selbst in jerusalem heulen die sirenen
sieben raketen schlagen in einem vorort
in einen kibbuz ein
die hamas hatte ein ultimatum bis 6 uhr
ortszeit gestellt abzug aller
sicherheitskräfte vom tempelberg kurs am
morgen heftige zusammenstöße gegeben
hatte und abzug aus dem auschecken gegen
palästinensische familien
zwar ist der angriff der planke terror
die palästinenser in jerusalem aber ich
bin glücklich dass die raketen aus gaza
geflogen sind sie sind gekommen um uns
zu unterstützen
gott sei dank zehntausende siedler und
zionisten waren zum jerusalem tag zur
erinnerung an die eroberung 1967
gekommen haben angriff diesen ausmaßes
hatte vorher keiner gerechnet
wir haben die kontrolle im land aber wir
wollen in frieden mit den arabern leben
aber frieden bedeutet dass sie nicht
randalieren keine steine werfen und wir
gehen können wohin wir wollen
die flaggenparade wurde nach dem
raketenalarm schnell aufgelöst aber noch
immer sind viele jüdische aktivisten in
der stadt neue zusammenstöße werden für
die nacht erwartet
michael bewerunge beobachtet für uns die
angespannte lage in israel michael warum
jetzt diese eskalation der gewalt die
hamas versucht schon seit einer ganzen
weile die sich anbahnenden spannungen
für sich auszuschlachten und zu nutzen
und weiter anzuheizen
das ganze findet ja in einem machtvakuum
stadt hier sind wahlen in palästina
abgesagt worden
das hat die hamas sehr bedauert und sehr
kritisiert und die hamas würde gerne
ihren einfluss speziell in der westbank
steigern
und nun hat sie eine möglichkeit mit
radikalen aktionen mehr anhänger zu
gewinnen punkte für sich zu machen wir
haben gesehen ist eine große
unterstützung und mehr anhänger für ihre
radikale politik gegen israel zu
gewinnen die reaktion der regierung
heute war das deutliche gegen angriffe
angekündigt worden sind allerdings erst
mal nur aus der luft vielen dank für
ihre schilderung der situation michael
bewerunge in tel aviv in jerusalem zur
krone situation da sinken die zahlen
weiter lockerung ist das wort der stunde
und fünf länder sollten jetzt gemeinsam
festlegen
wer unter welchen bedingungen wann
wieder öffnen kann fordert der
hauptgeschäftsführer des städte und
gemeindebundes landsberg gegenüber der
funke mediengruppe ab einer stabilen
incidents unter 100 können die
bundesländer die öffnung der
außengastronomie in den entsprechenden
regionen zu lassen
unter strengen auflagen acht
bundesländer verfahren so weitere vier
bundesländer werden das wohl bis
pfingsten gestatten vom rest der
republik sind keine öffnungs pläne
bekannt anselm stern beginnt sein
überblick in bayern wieder zusammen im
biergarten in bayern öffnet zumindest
draußen
zumindest da wo die virus zahlen besser
sind durchatmen mit aussicht hier am
ammersee nach den vielen dunklen
krisentagen glücksmoment und jetzt nach
diesem kann man fast sagen jahrelang
entzug wieder wieder mal der erstkontakt
die weiß eigentlich gar nicht wie ich
mich benehmen soll freude über mehr
freiheiten schon früher heute morgen
auch in passau etwa bei marie vesper
sie darf seit heute ihre terrasse
endlich wieder aufmachen die
stimmungslage insgesamt ziemlich gut
passau hat eine inzidenz von unter 25
wir freuen uns alle unheimlich es ist
ein großartiges gefühl hat gerade wo wir
die terrasse aufgesperrt haben sind wir
alle ganz euphorisch und freuen uns
richtig das würzige note geht neue alte
möglichkeiten heute auch in
niedersachsen aufgemacht werden hier
unter anderem die hotels allerdings
vorerst nur für gäste aus niedersachsen
immerhin wieder erste einnahmen der
stadt wirtschaftlich gesehen wäre schon
lange notwendig gewesen also die kassen
sind leer
es muss jetzt wieder losgehen wir können
nicht länger so durchhalten durchhalten
im bundesländer- regel flickenteppich
aus berlin aufrufe zur geduld das gefühl
ist im moment besser als die lage
wir sind immer noch auf sehr sehr hohem
niveau wir müssen jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen aufpassen dass wir nicht zu
früh in totale euphorie verfallen sagt
christian drosten doch er sagt auch dass
der sommer in deutschland er kann gut
werden bundesinnenminister seehofer ist
mit corona infiziert sein sprecher sagte
der 71 jährige sei in häuslicher
quarantäne und habe keine symptome
seehofer war im april einmal mit
biontech geimpft worden
bund und länder haben die priorisierung
für den corona impfstoff von johnson &
johnson aufgehoben wie bei astrazeneca
wird aber empfohlen ihn menschen ab 60
zu spritzen wegen seltene nebenwirkungen
bei jüngeren
doch nach ärztlicher beratung können
sich auch unter 60 jährige impfen lassen
der vorteil von johnson & johnson eine
impf spritze genügt für den vollen
schutz
die pandemie hat die schwächen des
deutschen bildungssystems offengelegt
nach mehr als einem jahr wechsel
unterricht und homeschooling hapert es
immer noch bei der digitalisierung und
der individuellen förderung
aber es gibt auch schulen die kreative
lösungen gefunden haben und dafür heute
ausgezeichnet wurden
sandlers trotz distanz unterricht damit
niemand auf der strecke bleibt an der
blautopf schule in blaubeuren baden
württemberg das besondere hier jeder
schüler hat einen lerncoach eine
lehrkraft als persönlichen begleiter
einmal die woche sprechen sie über
probleme lernziele deren erfolge
fachübergreifend im moment vor allem
digital
was brauchst du alles eine deine power
point digital ist inzwischen auch dieses
lernbüro mit materialien zum
individuellen lernen verfügbar auf einer
schuleigenen plattform
wir haben eben die materialien dann auch
für die kinder strukturiert so dass sie
dort auch sich orientieren können
dort lernen können mit diesen für sie
gemachten materialien besteht die
möglichkeit in jedem ort zu lernen
ich weiß ganz gut das wahrmachen was
bisschen anstrengend aber dann ging es
mit ihrem konzept haben sie es ins
finale des schulpreises geschafft
erreichen einem zweiten platz
schirmherr der bundespräsident der auch
mahnt die bekämpfung der pandemie lässt
öffentliche verschuldung steigen und des
kassensturz wird kommen aber an bildung
dürfen wir nicht sparen zum beispiel
beim nachholen versäumten stoff beim
abfedern sozialer folgen oder bei der
digitalisierung da haben deutsche
schulen durch corona zwar aufgeholt
stehen im internationalen vergleich aber
nach wie vor nicht besonders gut da wir
müssen uns auf diesen weg machen und wir
dürfen das was corona jetzt schon
angestoßen hat nicht wieder ad acta
legen darin sehe ich die größte gefahr
in blaubeuren wollen sie vorangehen und
mit ihrem modell auch beispiel für
andere schulen seien vier monate vor der
bundestagswahl haben die linken ihr
spitzenduo gekürt parteichefin janine
wissler und co fraktionschef dietmar
bartsch führen die partei in den
wahlkampf
punkten wollen sie vor allem mit dem
thema soziale gerechtigkeit pis lansky
hoch hinaus will die linke in diesem
wahlkampf gleich zweistellig die
zielmarke des spitzenduos janine wissler
die dem linken flügel zugerechnet wird
und dietmar bartsch erfahrener
parteistratege und pragmatiker für den
es der zweite anlauf ist der kampf gegen
die soziale spaltung ihr thema die
gesellschaft driftet auseinander unter
muss dagegen gearbeitet werden deshalb
wir brauchen eine große steuerreform
die zehn reichsten familien in
deutschland verfügen über ein vermögen
von 200
rund 40 milliarden das ist ob schöne
reichtum warum gibt es nicht die
bereitschaft hier etwas abzuholen
die linke die aus der opposition auf die
regierungsbank strebt will die
wirtschaft grundlegend umbauen notwendig
ist eine mutige eine radikale und eine
realistische politik es geht nicht um
kleine korrekturen sondern es geht um
einen richtungswechsel
wir wollen die prämissen der politik
grundlegend ändern umverteilen in einem
rot rot grünen bündnis doch die linke
lehnt auslandseinsätze und waffenexporte
ab regieren oder opponieren ein
richtungsstreit der längst nicht
entschieden ist der wahl eine mehrheit
jenseits der union gibt also alle drei
parteien der verantwortung diese eben
auch zu nutzen und ernsthaft zu schauen
welche projekte man auch umsetzen kann
fehlt noch das wahlprogramm das auf
einem parteitag im juni beschlossen
werden soll dann muss die linke farbe
bekennen
für die grünen geht annalena baerbock
ins rennen ums kanzleramt in was nun
frau baerbock wird sie sich den fragen
von peter frey und bettina schausten
stellen direkt nach dieser sendung nach
kolumbien wo es seit fast zwei wochen
massenproteste gegen die regierung gibt
oft von schweren ausschreitungen
überschattet
mehr als 20 menschen wurden getötet der
gewaltausbruch ist ein rückschlag für
das 50 millionen einwohner land das
jahrzehntelang unter einem brutalen
bürgerkrieg mit 220.000 menschen fielen
ihm zum opfer
2016 dann der friedensschluss mit der
links geriet danach ein aufschwung im
land doch die krawalle jetzt zeigen wie
gewaltig die spannungen immer noch sind
christa volker rath
ich bin keine zielscheibe und das land
ist mit blut getränkt steht auf den
plakaten unter denen sie liegen zwischen
den namen der toten
es sind vor allem junge leute die bei
den protesten in kolumbien umgekommen
viele so der vorwurf der demonstranten
durch die kugeln der sicherheitskräfte
wir sind hier um all der jungen menschen
zu gedenken die der stadt umgebracht hat
anstatt ihre rechte zu schützen bringt
der staat sie brutal zum schweigen
mit seinen killer an und
sicherheitskräften wir sind hier für die
würde unseres volkes
seit knapp zwei wochen erschüttern
unruhen kolumbien was mit protesten
gegen eine inzwischen zurückgezogene
steuerreform beginnt entwickelt sich zu
einer grundsätzlichen abrechnung vieler
mit dem start dem sie wachsende
ungleichheit korruption und willkür
vorwerfen
wir waren jetzt ein jahr im lok tor und
in dieser zeit des eingesperrtseins
wurden wir immer wütender
wir haben eine regierung die gegen ihr
eigenes volk ist die mehrzahl der
protest ist friedlich aber es gibt auch
blockaden plünderungen und gewalt und es
sind die sicherheitsorgane die so sagen
menschenrechtler auf alte muster aus
zeiten des bürgerkriegs zurückgreifen
sie schießen scharf der präsident hält
an der harten linie fest ruft aber auch
zum dialog ja zum dialog ja zum bau von
brücken ein klares nein zu blockaden ab
heute wollen sie wieder miteinander
reden in kolumbien
doch die risse durch die gesellschaft
sind tief deutlich mehr menschen
versuchen derzeit wieder über das
mittelmeer nach europa zu gelangen
auf der italienischen insel lampedusa
kamen allein seit gestern mehr als 2000
männer frauen und kinder an
damit wurden in italien seit
jahresbeginn rund 13.000 migrantinnen
registriert viele kommen aus tunesien
der elfenbeinküste und bangladesch
im vergangenen jahr waren es zum
gleichen zeitpunkt gut 4000 es ist ein
akt des ungehorsams was in vielen
katholischen gemeinden deutschlands
demonstrativ praktiziert wird
die segnung homosexueller paare unter
dem motto liebe gewinnt werden heute
bundesweit mehr als 100 dieser
gottesdienste abgehalten
eine aktion die sich gegen den vatikan
stellt der die segnung homosexueller
paare verboten hatte susanne gelhard
den tag des nova dem gott laut bibel den
regenbogen schenkte hat die initiative
der segnungsgottesdienst für
homosexuelle paare gewählt sie werden in
über 100 gemeinden am abend gefeiert
beifahrer allein häuser in winnweiler
wegen corona per livestream nicht mehr
heimlich sondern öffentlich es ist
unglaublich wichtig weil damit eben
nicht nur diesen paaren gezeigt wird ihr
müsst ihr nicht im verborgenen eure
beziehung leben sondern ihr könnt damit
ans licht gehen
eure beziehung etwas ganz normales und
ist es wichtig dass es auch in der
kirche gezeigt wird und da ein umdenken
anzustoßen
die segnung gleichgeschlechtlicher paare
das ist offener ungehorsam aus sicht des
vatikan der sein verbot erst kürzlich
erneuerte der vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz kritisierte
schriftlich er halte sie nicht für ein
hilfreiches zeichen und einen
weiterführenden weg segnungsgottesdienst
haben ihre eigene theologische würde und
pastorale bedeutung sie sind nicht als
instrument für kirchenpolitische
manifestationen oder protestaktionen
geeignet die paare und priester in der
ostkirche schweinfurt zeigen sich davon
jedoch unbeirrt
gott segne euch das sollte auch für alle
möglich sein jederzeit sich segnen zu
lassen vom vor dem pfarrer oder von der
von der kirche eben den zuspruch zu
bekommen da muss die kirche in vielen
bereichen einfach schritte gehen dass
das immer vor getan wird alles was
eigentlich passiert existiert wird und
sobald man das öffentlich macht ist es
ein großes drama sie hoffen dass sich
die katholische kirche künftig offener
zeigt und neue antworten findet das zdf
trauert um seinen zweiten intendanten
karl günther von hase er ist gestern im
alter von 103 jahren gestorben der
amtierende intendant thomas bellut
würdigt von hase als einen
zukunftsweisenden weichensteller von
hase wurde 1977 zum intendanten gewählt
der frühere diplomat baute die
internationale zusammenarbeit des zdf
aus er setzte sich außerdem für das
nebeneinander
von privaten und öffentlich rechtlichen
sendern ein
in seine amtszeit fiel auch der besuch
der queen beim zdf 1978 das zdf zeigt
die ausführliche würdigung des früheren
intendanten in dem film diplomat und
intendant um 23 55 nach dem
heute-journal update der deutsche
stararchitekt helmut jahn ist in seiner
wahlheimat usa bei einem fahrrad unfall
ums leben gekommen ob der messeturm in
frankfurt oder das sony center in berlin
die gebäude jahns prägen weltweit die
silhouetten von großstädten bahnhöfe
flughäfen bankgebäude in mehr als 700
projekten bewies der deutsch amerikaner
seine vielseitigkeit jahn wurde 81 jahre
alt
und nun zum tennis und zum sieg von
alexander zverev gestern abend in madrid
zum zweiten mal hatte hamburger dieses
top besetzten atp-turnier gewonnen
die deutsche nummer eins setzte sich im
finale gegen den italiener matteo
bertini nach hartem kampf mit 6 7 6 4
und 6 2 durch und wiederholte damit
seinen triumph aus dem jahr 2008 zehnter
es läuft richtig gut für alexander
zverev dieser turniersieg in
vorbereitung auf die french open in drei
wochen kann sich sehen lassen
großartig besonders nachdem ich letzte
woche das viertelfinale in münchen
verloren habe das hier ist echt cool ich
möchte es einfach genießen
den ersten satz verlor zverev im
tie-break 8 zu ziehen und auch im
zweiten satz wackelte der deutsche
doch der weltranglisten sechste behielt
die nerven gewann den satz mit 6 zu 4
und war dann im dritten satz voll da es
wäre heute beim stand von 2 2 das
entscheidende break
nutzte wenig später bei aufschlag
bettini seinen zweiten matchball zum 6
zu 3 satz und matchgewinn und beim
atp-turnier in rom hat soeben die
deutsche nummer 2 jan lennard struff
seinen auch sein auftaktspiel gegen den
slowenen alia spanien mit 6 zu 3 und 6 1
klar gewonnen
zum radsport und zum klassiker giro
d'italia da hat ja in der ta cco von der
horn überraschend die dritte etappe
gewonnen
nach 190 kilometern von biella nach
canale hatte der ausreißer einen
vorsprung von vier sekunden vor dem
heranrasenden feld in dem peter sagan
auf platz 3 sprintet sein deutsches
bohrer hansgrohe team hatte alles
mobilisiert aber es nicht ganz geschafft
die lücke zum ausreißer zu schließen
sagern links tritt spät aber wuchtig an
im kampf um platz zwei den der italiener
davide ki moon ab behauptet immerhin die
formkurve des dreimaligen weltmeisters
aus der slowakei steigt an
takko van der horn profi in einem
zweitklassigen belgischen team kann sein
glück kaum fassen
der 27-jährige giro debütant hat mit
seiner start-ziel flucht den großen
teams ein schnippchen geschlagen
das was uns schon nach dem schönen
sonntag gestern kommen die gewitter die
details gleich beim wetter von pisten
terry
das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse claus kleber erwartet sie um
drei viertel 10 zum heute-journal wir
sind morgen abend wieder hier und freuen
uns wenn sie dabei sind einen angenehmen
abend wünschen wir und jetzt geht es
hier weiter mit was nun frau bernburg
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter noch erreichte uns
warme luft aus dem süden europas und so
werden im osten deutschlands morgen bis
zu 30 grad erwartet im westen ist es
nicht mehr ganz so warm 15 grad hinter
der kaltfront in den östlichen
landesteilen gibt es dann zum nachmittag
teils kräftige gewitter in der nacht
wird es im westen dicht bewölkt sein mit
teils kräftigen regen und länger
andauernd blitz und donner sind hier
inklusive im osten und im südosten ist
es trocken mit tiefsten temperaturen bis
15 grad an der neiße und 9 grad in der
eifel
morgen vormittag viele wolken im westen
und hier regnet es kräftig und auch
länger andauert in den östlichen
landesteilen bis in den südosten ist es
trocken und zum nachmittag ziehen
schauer und gewitter weiter nach osten
und die können kräftiger ausfallen
bei höchsten temperaturen von bis zu 30
grad eine neue 15 grad in der eifel und
14 grad an der nordsee die kommenden
tage bleiben wechselhaft am mittwoch 10
bis 18 grad im westen auflockerungen so
ähnlich sieht es dann am donnerstag aus
und freitag weiterhin mit schauern und
gewittern ein schöner abend